I was in so many soon I was in a student
film last year a friend of mine took a
film class and I and I did a cameo
appearance in her like film 101 they
were really kind of gruesome slasher
ones and I remember the mostly because I
got so much fake blood on my clothes
which were my own clothes and I had to
throw the Mohawk ok I still try to do
them if I know the students or if I've
worked with them before because I think
it's exciting to work with new directors
and people that are coming right out of
film school they're very energetic about
it and excited and have ideas they put
so much work in and they're not jaded
and it's just that fresh new feeling
I love it I love working on Superman's
is there not a better time than now to
be a student filmmaker where you can
make it all on your camera and edit it
at home I wish I was a kid now and I
would become with the only piece of
advice I have they're probably sick of
hearing but make it make it yourself
make it now you can do that now you
couldn't well younger there's no point
waiting for somebody else to help you
make you just do it it takes so much to
shoot one minute of memory and eats any
minute you have you want to make sure
it's really working pre-production is
really important oh my god that's
something that you really understood
when you're first starting out take
risks have a vision and see it through
you're a failure is your best teacher
make and make and make and produce and
producer produce as much content as as
you can its meaning I think with that
passion eventually you sort of break
through the fray do it if it scares you
and don't make decisions based on fuel
if it scares you that's a reason to do
something and if you think you can
handle law school do law school
you